one of the the political predictions
that you've publicly made Matt is that
there's going to be some sort of
political violence unfolding this year
um or and at least you're you're worried
that that's going to happen um and part
of that uh seems to come down
to how people view what has transpired
in this country over the past four or
five years um
specifically you know the the Touchstone
there is January 6 and you you wrote a a
piece that I think drew a lot of fire
calling out uh V ramas Swami's comments
on January 6 let me pull that up here
the headline is V ramaswami really
really wants you to know he thinks
January 6 was an inside job um and uh I
highlighted a passage from here this is
what V had to say about January 6
there's now clear evidence that there
was at the very least entrapment of
peaceful protesters similar to the fake
Gretchen Witcher Gretchen Whitmer
kidnapping plot the FBI won't admit how
many undercover officers there were in
the field on January 6 Capital police on
one hand fired rubber bullets and
explosives into a peaceful crowd who
then then they willingly later allowed
to enter the capital that doesn't add up
if the Deep state is willing to
manufacture an Insurrection to take down
its political opponents they can do
anything once you see it you can't unsee
it what is the fundamental problem with
uh ramas Swami's formulation there and
um what are your worries about how this
kind of
increasingly uh that that that if this
formulation is increasingly accepted or
or embraced by mainstream political
figures years how how what effect um are
you worried that that's going to have on
American Civil Life that is not clear
evidence of entrapments or the
manufacturer of an Insurrection it is
not it is not that's not clear evidence
of that um you like show me the clear
evidence it's the beginning noting that
there are um there's been an admission
that at least a handful of FBI
informants were uh in the field that day
um and that's by the FBI uh in hearings
over the summer um uh noting that is not
clear evidence it is the beginning of a
series of questions um and those
questions then should lead you to where
uh the next place that you would find
evidence for this especially if you're
going to say that this is very similar
to the Gretchen Whitmer kidnapping uh in
which like so many cases after 911 the
FBI had people uh like uh people who
were pretending to be people that they
were not not just informants not just
sort of like uh like saying hey these
guys over here are doing it they they
were cooking up the plot themselves to
kidnap gret and Whitmer a plot that was
never going to happen it's private among
a small group of uh somewhat gullible
people uh we've seen this over and over
again we've written about this over and
over again at reason including back uh
long before Vic ramaswami uh expressed
any interest in the subject in any kind
of public way um so uh the next place
that you would look in a place like gret
and Whitmer is like okay um is testimony
from those people's part of the charging
documents in the case um is it part of
the criminal conviction one it goes to
trial in those entrapment cases they
were and that is typically how that goes
that's how we learn about it that's how
in the case of Michigan uh some of those
charges were thrown out although they
were then retried um in the
889 convictions that have happened uh
related to the January 6 riots in
Capitol Hill uh 200 of which involved
violent activity um there has been zero
cases as far as we know as far as I'm
aware of um in which that showed up in
the charging documents and that was part
of the trial testimony evidence from
Agents provocators informants in the
field um so if this is clear evidence it
would show some fingerprints somewhere
unless uh I'm still holding out the
possib here in general like we should
suspect the FBI having a default
suspicion and a deep one is totally fine
so then where do you look so the way
that that uh you can imagine that this
was um uh that we wouldn't need to use
that testimony that could have been
there is just by simply um that the
actions of the people um you know
charging through barricades uh causing
injury to more than 100 Capital police
um that their actions alone were enough
to convict them but that should lead you
to and so therefore they didn't need
this testimony even though they could
have totally done it but that should
lead you to another conclusion which is
to say the way that you avoid that kind
of entament and let's remember that
since I wrote that article uh thec has
now called January 6 um entrapment day
um the way to avoid entrapment is to not
uh bust through barricades and break
windows and fight with Capitol police
officers while trying to enter the
capital building
um on the day that they're supposed to
be certifying the president election you
could totally avoid it by not doing any
of those things and I don't say that
cheekily and I don't say that in a way
to be like high-fiving these grossly
long sentences uh various proud boys
members I don't think that the
Insurrection um uh the Sedition charges
I I don't think that that those were
appropriate I think they're way too long
um I agree with viac ramaswami that
people who are nonviolent shouldn't be
serving prison for their activities on
that day um I agree with him um so uh
but it's not clear evidence of
entrapment it just isn't and uh and he
also said that the Capitol Police are
just the same as the FBI no they're not
they're different they're actually
different organizations um and if the
Capitol Police and the other two things
that he's pointing to as as clear bits
of evidence were like well look um they
you know they did tear gas and Weber
Bullets Over Here although very small
amounts um um but they let in you
barricades over here so look they're
just like letting them right in that
doesn't add up it's a chaotic scene if
you have a if you anyone who has been in
a riot knows that it doesn't add up
riots are crazy moments like everyone is
acting in strange ways and if the
Capitol Hill Police were in on it that
means that they ushered in first of all
that means that all of the interviews
that have been done with them they all
managed to just sort of like um uh be
completely disciplined about not
spilling the beans on the worst day in
the history history of the capital
police they're like okay we'll just
totally swallow this conspiracy it's
hard a single whistleblower yeah but
people would have to be in cahoots for
all of this to add up right like it
would have to be hundreds and hundreds
of people who've all perfectly synced up
their stories with not a crack in sight
and not even anybody privately sort of
admitting to their groups of friends
what's what right I I do want to get to
to the beginning of Zach's question
which is yeah um because it's not
one-sided it's not just January 6th is
my uh worry about violence the way that
I'm worried about violence related to
January 6th is that it is clear that the
Republican party uh the mainstream of
the Republican party is not taking
responsibility for January 6th um uh
like clear majorities when you poll
Republicans either blame it like on
antifa or the FBI or Ray EPS or whoever
is in their imagination who did it U or
they say yeah it's fine um like it's
Justified because Biden stole the
election so like that's not taking
responsibility for Human Action at all
you have to like own the agency of it
one way or the other in my estimation or
else you are basically intellectually
greenlighting further violence and on
the left that is the same um in
different ways but that overall Dynamic
is the same with the 2020 uh post George
Floyd riots which killed you know 14 19
people I forget the the exact number
huge amounts of damage and not just that
but Portland was on fire for a 100
consecutive days people were just like
uh you know besieging and throwing human
uh at the uh police building in
Downtown Portland over and over there's
burning stuff day after day we boarded
up New York City Manhattan which I don't
think is a trump uh a you know a big
Trump supporting region we put plywood
on Windows here because we assumed that
if Trump won the people who didn't like
him would Riot so that says to me that
we've normalized a lot of political
violence and the post October 7th
demonst ations which I mentioned before
which do irritate me to great effect
because it it keeps me from getting home
uh and that's that's just no good um if
we're allowing small groups of raggedy
ass protesters to close Bridges to uh
prompt the evacuation of the White House
which happened the other day um that
says to me that we haven't thought we
haven't come up with a plan on what to
do if you uh behavior that gets rewarded
gets repeated in the famous formulation
and so if that all it takes is a couple
of beer s and some college dropouts to
block a bridge that well that seems fun
let's block O'Hare Airport let's snack
the worst thing is that they're not
College dropouts they in fact graduated
from their liberal arts schools and now
want uh loan forgiveness from the rest
of us so uh you know it's important to
note that but I I do also I I was
confused by the boarding up of Windows
all up and down Fifth Avenue um on
Election Day uh this past go around as
well especially because one of the
things that was most striking to me was
that sleep number The Mattress Store was
boarded up and I'm a little bit like
were you seriously expecting the Looting
of mattresses um in Manhattan like how
exactly was that going to go like please
play this out for me but you get tired
and like from a long night of rioting
and need a little rest but I think your
point is well taken and I think it you
your writing on this actually kind of at
least shakes me out of this mindset
where since this has just been the state
of play for the last I don't know
frankly since 2020 Summer of 2020 post
George Floyd it was very much
normalized but even before that a little
bit we saw Zach and I were just talking
recently about all of the um you know
Carnage in Ferguson Missouri and
basically how that was sort of you know
obviously there have been different
waves of protests La in the 90s is
another good example that you mentioned
earlier there have been these waves of
protests and riots that have popped up
but to some degree I kind of feel like
from 2014 and then we had a little pause
when things were kind of good and decent
from 2016 to 2020 and then 2020 up until
now these eras where it feels like small
groups of people exerting extraordinary
influence um and really affecting other
people's abilities to live their lives
uh people you know shopkeepers abilities
to actually uh earn a living for
themselves people's abilities to go out
their business unmolested it's kind of
increasingly rare and it's it's
important to kind of whip our heads snap
our heads out of this and remember
living in such a political
tumultuous era is not a normal thing
this is not aspirational this is not
good this is not how every single era
has totally been though obviously there
have been these waves of it but at least
for the last four years the fact that
this is at least to me feels like a fact
of life is a hugely problematic thing
where it does like political violence is
sort of increasingly um it's like we
increasingly act like if it's for the
right cause it's no big deal and
actually it's really important to say no
no matter the cause it's a really
big deal yeah I think that's the
key point is that the the excusing of it
by the the and the cowardice from
political leaders to condemn political
violence uh if it's coming from your
side more or less that that's what we're
what Matt is describing with January 6
that's what we saw with these riots and
uh that that denying of uh personal
agency which I would think is something
that Libertarians would be particularly
attuned to and and able to recognize
like the importance of agency and
responsibility but I I do think it's
becoming an increasingly unbridgeable
divide among Libertarians uh and other
small government types who more or less
believe what Ras Swami says about
January 6 and the leadup to it and those
of us who think there's there might be
some shadiness there might have been
some egging on but don't see the
evidence of some massive setup and
that's not even to say that the entire
Insurrection framing or narrative is
exactly right either I I just think
there's a there's a lot of contributing
factors and and blame to go around which
you can trace all the way back to if you
wanted the beginnings of the Trump
Administration and the Russia
investigation and the the the discontent
uh I think a lot of it uh legitimate
about how that was handled the
outrageous the the the lies and the bad
policy around covid the media the the
political hypocrisy and defenses of
looting it's that it's all a valid
discussion but if one of us believes
that January 6 was a manufactured plot
to stop us from discovering the truth
and the other just doesn't see the
evidence for that it's it's such a
different view of reality
hey thanks for watching that clip from
our new show just asking questions you
can watch another clip here or the full
episode here new episodes drop every
week so subscribe to reent TV's YouTube
channel to get notified when that
happens or to the just asking questions
podcast on Apple Spotify or any other
podcast